PROFESSOR: The
Phase Lines mathlet
helps us to understand
the behavior
of nonlinear
autonomous equations.
The large graphing window
shows a direction field.
The horizontal axis is t,
and the vertical axis is y.
As you see, the direction
field is independent of t.
This is the significance
of an autonomous equation.
The applet opens with the
equation 1 minus y times y
minus a, but I want to talk to
you about a different equation,
namely this one, which can
be written as the quantity
a minus y, times y, minus 1/4.
This is a logistic
equation with harvesting.
Specifically, this is a
model of the oryx population
in a certain game
preserve in Kenya,
measured in kilooryx and years.
The Kenyan government
wants to sell permits
to kill 1/4 kilooryx
per year, and it
wants to know how
large a game preserve
it should create to guarantee
a stable oryx population.
The size of the
preserve determines
what would be the limiting
population of oryx which
is the number a.
We can use this
applet to explore
the options to recommend
to the Kenyan government.
We can control the parameter
a using this slider down here.
Right now, it's
set to a equals 0,
so the equation
is y prime equals
minus 1/4 minus y squared,
always negative, so all
the solutions decrease.
With a game preserve
of zero area,
the population is
guaranteed to collapse.
We can draw some solution curves
by clicking on this window.
You'll notice that any
horizontal translate
of the solution is another
solution to this differential
equation.
This is another
consequence of the fact
that it's an autonomous
differential equation.
We can increase the value
of a using this slider.
And when I do, notice that
the change in the direction
field-- it starts to flatten
out, especially in an area just
above the t-axis.
And when a takes on
the value 1, a solution
appears, a constant
solution in blue.
This is an equilibrium solution.
We can measure the
value of y along it.
There's a readout
below the screen.
It seems that y is about 1/2.
And if we take a equals
1 and y equals 1/2,
and plug those values
into this equation,
you will get y prime equals 0.
In other words, you get
a constant solution.
Now notice this parabola in
the lower left of the screen.
As I change a, it moves.
That parabola is the graph of
y prime as a function of y.
So it depends upon a.
When a moves up to
the value a equals 1,
the parabola moves
up and touches
the y-axis at the
value y equals 1/2.
Now this blue curve represents
a steady-state solution,
but the Kenyan
government would be
ill-advised to use a
preserve only this big.
Because random fluctuations
will occasionally
drive the population of
oryx below y equals 1/2,
and as soon as that
happens, disaster ensues.
The population is
guaranteed to collapse.
So let's take a bigger game
preserve, make a larger,
and when you do that,
the parabola moves up,
the blue double root
splits into two roots,
and the equilibrium solution
bifurcates into two equilibrium
solutions.
The red equilibrium is unstable.
Solutions near to
it diverge from it.
In fact, solutions below
it approach infinity.
These curves become asymptotic
to vertical straight lines.
They blow up in finite time.
Solutions between
the two equilibria
move from the lower
equilibrium up
to the green upper
equilibrium, and solutions
above the green equilibrium
decay towards it.
The green solution is
a stable equilibrium.
You can see this behavior
by looking at the parabola
as well.
If the value of y is
less than the red zero,
the value of the
parabola is negative.
Solutions are falling.
Between the two roots, the
value of y prime is positive.
Solutions are growing.
And to the right of
this equilibrium,
the value of y
prime is negative.
Solutions are falling again.
You can see all this very neatly
using the phase line, which I
can invoke using this key here.
The phase line carries all
the information present
in the direction field, but
in a much more compact form.
You can see the two
equilibria marked,
and below this equilibrium,
all the solutions are decaying.
Between the two, the
solutions are all increasing,
and above the upper equilibrium,
the solutions are all decaying.
These are indicated by
these yellow arrows.
Now the Kenyan government
has some leeway.
It may predict an
accidental variation
of, say, 1/2 kilooryx.
In that case, it should
arrange a game preserve large
enough so that the distance
between the two critical points
is at least 1/2.
Then, assuming that
the initial population
is close to this equilibrium,
a deviation of 1/2
won't be a disaster,
because the population
will recover and return
to the stable equilibrium.
Well, we've come a long way.
We're now looking at a family
of differential equations,
when indexed by the parameter a.
Each value of a has its
own direction field,
its own set of critical
points, it's own solutions,
and its own phase line.
But as we see, for
practical policy reasons,
it's important to be
able to consider them
all simultaneously.
The bifurcation diagram
lets you do exactly that.
Let's invoke it
with this check box.
The diagram has appeared
above the a slider.
In it is marked a curve.
This curve consists of
all the critical points
for these differential
equations for all values of a,
marked simultaneously.
The critical points
for a given value of a
appear above that value
of a in the slider.
So here's the phase line for
this value of a containing
an unstable critical point
and a stable critical point.
And when I change
the value of a,
that phase line
changes and moves.
And as the value of a
decreases to a equals 1,
those two critical
points collide and form
a single semi-stable
critical point.
For smaller values of a,
there are no critical points,
until you reach the
value a equals minus 1,
when a single semi-stable
critical point appears and then
bifurcates into two critical
points for smaller values of a.
The critical curve
is color coded
according to the type
of critical point
that it represents.
The bifurcation diagram
takes place in the a-y plane.
It's the curve defined by the
equation y prime equals 0.
In this case, that's minus
1/4 plus a*y minus y squared.